Bueno es un momento histórico En
definitiva para lo que serían las
relaciones entre India y Estados Unidos
y creo que llega muy bien en un momento
de mucha atención en todo lo que es Asia
primero Resaltar los aplausos
importantes que ha tenido durante toda
su su disertación y algunos hechos que
simbolizan lo que son las relaciones
actuales entre Estados Unidos India
primero las palabras de viejos amigos o
amigos cercanos o sea se marca una
cierta relación que se ha fructificado
en todo este tiempo pero más se le Abre
las pruebas de amistad habla de lo que
serían las letras Ai o sea de Estados
Unidos y en India donde recibe varias
veces aplausos en pie realmente habla
bastante de la Democracia de su
democracia creo que es el momento más
importante en su discurso y habla de dos
grandes democracias la más vieja que la
norteamericana y la más numerosa que es
la democracia India Me parece que hay
algún anuncio interesante en cuanto a
una frase que es vital para esto ayudar
cuando se necesiten y que él está siendo
llamado para el llamado para el siglo
llamado para el siglo debe ser el ápice
más importante de lo que sería su charla
de su de su disertación ya que eso marca
directamente Cuál va a ser la posición
de India en el futuro en su relación con
Estados Unidos y con el mundo occidental
Carlos hizo muchísimo hincapié en la
democracia Por qué cree que lo hizo
Quizás por este contexto de ciertas
críticas que está sufriendo sobre
presuntas violaciones a los derechos
humanos en India
Santiago es justamente tu pregunta la
más indicada él recibió y lo vimos en la
conferencia que dio hace un ratito
algunas críticas por parte de algunos
parlamentarios no todos están en el
parlamento norteamericano hoy algunos
demócratas este faltaron por así decir
con aviso naturalmente hay algunos
detalles en la democracia hindú en este
momento que hacen a ese debilitamiento
que tiene la democracia a nivel diría
que de otros países tenemos que ser
sinceros Y justos en este caso
latinoamérica también tiene problemas de
democracia en muchos países
latinoamericanos no obstante seguimos
confiando en la democracia y seguimos
apostando cada día más en la democracias
estamos presentes a una de las
democracias más más participativas y él
habla mucho democracia justamente por
eso hay hay un intento de poner Al mismo
nivel India de Estados Unidos en cuanto
a valores democráticos y él lo está
intentando hacer en este discurso
narendra hizo una referencia comenzó
Hablando de su visita en el año 2016 No
cuando el presidente en aquel entonces
era Barack Obama no hablemos de la
importancia en particular de Esta visita
no en el año 2023 no A diferencia de lo
que ocurría en el 2016 cómo estaban en
aquel momento los vínculos Pero qué
intereses tienen hoy más marcados en el
justamente Santiago Hoy hay intereses
muy importantes entre las dos naciones
lo primero es intentar el bloqueo de
compra frecuentes que tenía India de
armamento Ruso y en especial en la
compra de petróleo ruso a cantidades
importantes y a un precio muy barato
creo que eso ya quedó Y eso hoy
subsanado con los anuncios de compra de
aviones que son muy importantes y
algunos anuncios en cuanto a la
elaboración de motores para aviones pero
en especial el anuncio donde los dos
países van a armar un programa lunar y a
marte a futuro eso marca una relación
militar y de información y transferencia
de información muy importante estados
unidos no ha hecho estos anuncios muy
seguidos la verdad es que estoy buscando
en los análisis no sería la primera vez
eso marca un relacionamiento entre los
dos países de importancia y histórica
por lo que estamos viviendo en el día de
hoy En definitiva también vemos una
sustitución de la cadena de suministros
de China algunos anuncios importantes en
los procesadores y chips que se
instalarían en India y sustituirían la
industria china en especial la taiwanesa
por algunas situaciones que se pueden
llegar a dar y también vemos que hay
algún interesante avance lo que serían
los metales importantes o metales
estratégicos en en todo esto realmente
es un momento donde si simplin lo está
mirando debe estar un poco más nervioso
que la semana pasada en términos
militares de defensa digamos se abre una
nueva etapa para India y Estados Unidos
y también para China
es verdad Estados Unidos India ya tenía
un acuerdo muy importante el primer
anuncio que hizo biden cuando asumió fue
relanzar el quad el quad es una
organización de defensa militar y
paramilitar que nuclea Australia Japón
India y Estados Unidos los cuatro países
con más problemas con china en este caso
en China es un país que ha tenido en
estos últimos años mayor conflicto con
china recordemos lo que ocurrió en el
2020 en aquella escaramuza que sucedió
en el en el Himalaya pero hoy la
población India tiene la peor
perspectiva y la más negativa en
relación a China porque desde la guerra
de 1962 recordemos que India además no
deja el uso del tiktok Y no dejó que
Huawei se instalara con el 5g las
relaciones en esa frontera y en especial
a sumar y al uso de las Islas la ha
llevado a este tipo de situaciones y
realmente lo que está sucediendo es una
de las instancias más interesantes de
estos de este año ahora podemos hablar
también de un modismo de aquel que
visitó Estados Unidos en el 2016 hay un
hecho no que se destaca en muchísimos
medios muchísimos analistas que es el
haber hecho parte de esta rueda de
prensa conjunta no no siendo una persona
que muy habitualmente
de entrevistas
Santiago de la rueda conjunta y que va y
de la hora va a dar la tercera escena de
gala en su casa en la historia de su
mandato a modi eso marca también no
forma relacionamiento entre otros dos
son viejos amigos realmente voy ha
sufrido en algún en el pasado algún
problema relacionado a lo que podría ser
alguna crítica hacia la etnia musulmana
hay algunas manifestaciones que también
se dan ahora por parte de la etnia
musulmana
establecida en cachemira Pero eso no no
dicta de que Estados Unidos encuentre en
él uno de los aliados a futuro más
interesantes recordemos que además India
no había condenado fehacientemente la
invasión de Ucrania y con esto Me parece
que también está la estrategia de
intentar de que un país que siempre fue
muy independiente que no hizo parte de
ninguno de los dos grandes polos
mundiales hoy tome participación en uno
de ellos o por lo pronto que esté más
adecuado a la situación de lo que sería
occidente o el mundo occidental el
discurso del de modi es Claro en ese
sentido sus amigos
su sus mejores amigos Están de este lado
y él está pronto para el llamado de este
siglo es claro el mensaje que está
pasando